I never would have thought after losing
my legs I will do hundreds of marathons
Krieger shibor is gearing up for his
ultimate competition his sixth and final
Paralympic Games in Rio he's originally
from South Africa but he'll be competing
for Team USA it's the last stretch in a
journey that started decades ago I lost
my legs in the military in 1987 when I
was 24 years old I was a runner at
school and our swimmer and a rugby
player you name it I did it all after
the accident he searched for a new way
to compete that's when he found hand
cycling now with one last chance to
score a Paralympic gold medal he's
banking on the latest in cycling tech to
give him a boost I'm not young anymore I
do see over time that I needed smaller
things to give me a little extra edge so
he turned to Chris Peterson the founder
of carbon bike USA our bikes are all
carbon fiber the frame before cranks and
that really helps reduce the weight for
example the bike for Creed's abort he's
a lightweight guy being the wfp too if
his bike is super stiff it will bounce
down the road and the whole bike being
made out of carbon fiber now is it's a
few pounds lighter than his old aluminum
bike depending he really is looking for
is to be stable in the corners and be
able to accelerate quickly as the sport
became competitive in the 90s racers
shifted from sitting upright to a more
aerodynamic position but there's still
room for the technology to advance day
the games are over the games are over
and we need to start making better bikes
for the next game
new material is being developed whether
it's just other composites besides
carbon fiber and that stuff that we're
looking at also to see if we can make it
lighters better may be less expensive
it's an evolution there are so many
different bikes nowadays on on the
market and it almost come to a point
where all of them are on the same pain
level but then you have smaller things
that really makes the difference to an
athlete that want to go that mixed it
it's my final year at the Paralympian I
will still compete and fun with it but
not at this level was being there's been
great journey for me there's another
journey ahead